i have to ask about april 2012
when uh instagram
along with its massive
employee base of 13 people was sold to
facebook for one billion dollars what
was the process like on a business level
engineering level human level what was
that process of selling to facebook like
what did it feel like
so i want to provide some context which
is i worked in corporate development at
google
which not a lot of people know but
corporate development is effectively the
group that buys companies right you sit
there and you acquire companies and i
had sat through so many of these
meetings with entrepreneurs we actually
fun fact we never acquired a single
company when i worked in corporate
development so i can't claim that
um i had like a lot of experience
um
but i had enough experience to
understand okay like what prices are
people getting and what's the process
and
and as we started to grow
you know
we were trying to keep this thing
running and we were exhausted and we
were 13 people and i mean we were
trying to think back it's probably 27
37 now
um so
young
and on a relative basis right
and uh we're trying to keep the thing
running and then you know we go out to
raise money and
we're kind of like the hot startup at
the time and i remember going into a
specific vc and saying our terms we're
looking for are we're looking for a 500
million dollar valuation
and i've never seen so many jobs drop
all in unison right
and i was like thanked and walked out
the door very kindly after
um and then i got a call the next day uh
from someone who was connected to them
and said they said
we just want to let you know that like
uh it was pretty offensive that you
asked for a 500 billion evaluation and i
i can't tell if that was um
like just negotiating or what but it's
true like no one offered us more right
so we were so can you clarify the the
number again you said how many million
500 500 million 500 million yeah half a
billion yeah um
so in my mind i'm anchored like okay
well literally no one's biting at 500
million and eventually we would get
sequoia and greylock and others together
at 500 million basically uh post it was
450 pre i think we raised 50 million
but just like no one was used to seeing
500 million dollar companies then like i
i don't know if it was because we were
just coming out of
the hangover 2008 and things were still
on recovery um mode
uh but then along comes facebook and
after some negotiation
we've 2xed the number from a half a
billion to a billion yeah it seems
pretty good
you know
and uh
i think mark and i really saw eye to eye
that this thing could be big um we
thought we could
their resources would help us scale it
and in a lot of ways de-risks i mean it
degrees a lot of the employees lives for
the rest of their lives including me
including mike right
um i think i might have had like 10
grand in my bank account at the time
right like
we're working hard we had nothing um
so on a relative basis it seemed
very high and then
i think the last company to exit for
anywhere close to a billion was youtube
that i could think of
and uh and thus began the giant long
bull run of 2012 to all the way all the
way to where we are now where um i saw
some stat yesterday about like how many
unicorns exist and it's absurd
but then again never underestimate
technology and like the value it can
provide and man costs have dropped and
man scale has increased and
you can make businesses make a lot of
money now but on a on a fundamental
level
i don't know like how do you describe
the decision to sell a company with 13
people for a billion dollars so first of
all like how
did it take a lot of guts to set a table
and say 500 million or 1 billion with
mark zuckerberg it seems like a very
large number with 13. like especially
like it doesn't seem it is it is they're
all large especially like you said
before
the unicorn
parade
i like that i'm going to use that
unicorn yeah the uh the the you are at
the head of the unicorn parade it's the
uh yeah it's a massive unicorn parade um
okay so
no i mean we knew we were worth
quote-unquote a lot but we didn't there
was no market for instagram i mean it's
not you could mark you couldn't mark to
market this thing in the public markets
you didn't quite understand what it
would be worth or it was worth at the
time
so in a market an illiquid market where
you have one buyer and one seller and
you're going back and forth and
well i guess there were
like vc firms who were willing to
you know invest at a certain valuation
so
i don't know you just go with your gut
and uh and at the end of the day i would
say
the hardest part
of it was not realizing uh
like when we sold it was tough because
like literally everywhere i go
restaurants whatever like
for a good six months after there was a
lot of attention on the deal a lot of
attention on the product a lot of
attention it was kind of miserable right
and you're like wait like i made a lot
of money but like why is this not great
and it's because it turns out you know
and i don't i don't know like i don't
really keep in touch with mark but i've
got to assume his job right now is not
exactly the most happy job in the world
it's really tough when you're on top and
it's really tough when you're in the
limelight
so the decision itself was like oh cool
this is great how lucky are we right so
okay there's a million questions yeah go
first of all first of all
why
why is it hard to be on top why did you
not feel good
like can you dig into that it always um
i've heard like olympic athletes say
after what they win gold they they get
depressed
is it something like that where it feels
like
it was kind of like a thing you were
working towards yeah some some loose
definition of success and this sure
feels like
uh at least according to other startups
this is what success looks like and now
why don't i feel any
better i'm still human i still have all
the same problems is that the nature or
is it just like negative attention of
some kind what i think it's all of the
above um but to be clear there was a lot
of happiness in terms of like oh my god
this is great like we
like won the super bowl of startups
right um anyone who
can get to a liquidity event of anything
meaningful feels like wow this is what
we started out to do of course we want
to create great things that people love
but
um
like we won in a big way but yeah
there's this big like oh if we won what
is like what's next i don't so
they call it the we have arrived
syndrome um
which i i'd need to go back and look
where i can quote that from but i
remember reading about it at the time i
was like oh yeah that's that
i remember we had a product manager
leave very early on when we got to
facebook and he said to me um i just
don't believe i can learn anything at
this company anymore it's like it's hit
its
apex we sold it great
i just don't have anything else to learn
so from 2012 all the way to the day i
left in 2018 like the amount i learned
and the humility with which i realized
oh we thought we won
a billion dollars is cool but like there
are a hundred billion dollar companies
and by the way on top of that
we had no revenue we had i mean we had a
cool product but we didn't scale it yet
and
there's so much to learn and then
competitors and how fun was it to fight
snapchat oh my god like it was
it's like yankees red sox it's great
like that's what you live for um
you know you win some you lose some but
uh the amount you can learn through that
process uh
what i've realized
in life is that there is no end there's
always someone who has more there's
always more challenge just at different
scales
and uh this sounds a like a little
buddhist but um
everything is super challenging whether
you're like a small business or an
enormous business
i say like choose the game you like to
play
right you've got to imagine that if
you're an amazing basketball player you
enjoy to some extent practicing
basketball it's got to be something you
love it's going to suck it's gonna be
hard
you're gonna have injuries right but you
gotta love it and the same thing with
instagram which is
um
we might have sold but it was like great
there's one super bowl title can we win
five what else can we do
now i imagine you didn't ask this but
okay so i left
there's a little bit of like what do you
do next right like what do you how do
you top that thing it's the wrong
question
the question is like when you wake up
every day what is the hardest most
interesting thing you can go work on
because like at the end of the day we
all turn into dirt doesn't matter right
but what does matter is like can we
really enjoy this life
not in a hedonistic way because that's
those tr it's like the reinforcement
learning learning like short-term versus
long-term objectives
can you wake up every day and truly
enjoy what you're doing
um
knowing that it's gonna be painful
knowing that like no matter what you
choose it's going to be painful whether
you sit on a beach or whether you manage
a thousand people or 10 000 it's going
to be painful so choose something that's
fun
to have pain
um but yes there was uh there was a lot
of we have arrived and um
it's a maturation process you just have
to go through so no matter how much
success is there is how much money you
make you have to wake up the next day
and choose the hard life whatever that
means next that's fun the fun slash hard
life well hard life that's fun i guess
what i'm trying to say is slightly
different which is just that no one
realizes everything's gonna be hard
even chilling out
is hard and then you just start worrying
about stupid stuff like i don't know
like
did so and so forget to paint the house
today or like did the gardener come or
whatever like yeah or oh i'm so angry
and my shipment of wine didn't show up
and i'm sitting here on the beach
without my wine i don't know i'm making
[ __ ] up now but like it turns out that
even chilling aka meditation is hard
work yeah i and at least meditation is
like productive chilling where you're
like actually training yourself to calm
down and be but
backing up for a moment
everything's hard you might as well be
like
playing in the game you love to play i
just like playing and winning and
and i'm i'm
on the on the i'm still on the i think
the first half of life knock on wood um
and i've got a lot of years what am i
going to do sit around and the other way
of looking at this by the way
um
imagine you made one movie and it was
great
would you just like stop making movies
no generally you're like wow i really
like making movies let's make another
one a lot of times by the way the second
one or the third one not that great but
the fourth one awesome and no one
forgets the sec or everyone forgets the
second and the third one so there's just
this constant process of like can i
produce
and is that fun is that exciting what
else can i learn so this machine
learning stuff for me has been this
awesome new chapter of being like
man that's something i didn't understand
at all and now i feel like i'm one tenth
of the way there
and that feels like a big mountain to
climb
you